orphan black star Jordan Viveiros  reveals he is gay sort of pondering the  Who am I of life the 27 year old actor  who plays Felix on the hit show says he  came out to his family when he was 19  years old but in a new interview with  vulture Jordan shares why he is finally  addressing his sexuality publicly quote  I've never been asked adding I hope that  one day the world gets to a place where  you don't need to politicize your  sexuality that no one's afraid maybe to  come out jordan says he believes your  sexual orientation shouldn't matter as  my lesbians in my bed loss and shared  how he feels being openly gay might  affect his career moving forward quote I  do believe that jobs will be lost and I  do believe jobs will be gained maybe not  even for the right reasons as for his  love life  Jordan is dating Dexter star Devon gray  the two met through his orphans co-star  Tatiana maslany  you